[Applaudissements]
petit je saute je suis tombé dans une
barrique une barrique rempli d'eau
j'apprends les la technique d'épuration
des eaux usées et de l'eau potable et je
poursuis cette aventure sur
l'électricité
cette aventure de formation c'est sur
l'électricité un ami vos amis
d'électricité par rapport à l'eau mais
tout aussi intéressant et donc du coup
cette matière l'eau gelée jamais quitté
elle m'a toujours suivi dans le fil de
ma formation et de mes activités
professionnelles
en 2009 j'ai le choix entre deux cdi
dans un grand groupe mondial distribuant
de l'eau et pour des raisons familiales
et climatique
je choisi bordeaux a changé et donc du
coup cdc des retraités qui qui va
aujourd'hui des retraités qui
m'apprennent à travailler à faire
fonctionner une station d'épuration et
donc du coup
ces personnes là m'ont vraiment appris
la vie et est là et ce métier qui est
apporté de l'eau et donc du coup j'ai
toujours suivi cette idée de si jeunesse
savait si vieillesse pouvait donc j'ai
toujours j'ai appris donc ces trois
techniques d'épuration des eaux usées
qui sont
parmi les quatre existantes et donc peu
de temps peu de temps après ce premier
post sur les stations d'épuration jeu
j'avais appris qu'on me prenait quand
vous pouvez correctement géré une
station d'épuration qu'en gérant
correctement son réseau d'assainissement
et donc du coup les services de ce grand
groupe étant bien cloisonné je demande à
changer de changer de poste et donc du
coup je me retrouve sur ce réseau
d'assainissement et la gestion de d'un
réseau d'eaux pluviales qui est assez
impressionnant sur bordeaux et grâce à
grâce à ces deux postes je fais une
validation des acquis de l'expérience
pour obtenir un bts en gestion maîtrise
de l'eau et là de nouvelles aventures
s'offre à moi car je prends un poste de
télé contrôleur assainissement une tour
de contrôle de l'image de ce qui se peut
se passer dans l'aviation qui gère tout
le réseau d'assainissement d'eaux
pluviales et tout le réseau
tout le réseau d'assainissement et tout
le réseau d'eaux pluviales et donc
l'émission de qui me sont confiées
pendant deux ans et de lutter contre les
inondations de bordeaux lorsqu'il pleut
et lorsqu'il fait beau de lutter contre
les pollutions dues miniature du milieu
naturel et 1,1 en données jeu
je choisis en conscience je choisis en
conscience de quitter suez de quitter
d'obtenir ma d'obtenir ma liberté et
donc je crée une entreprise ayant ayant
un an auparavant participé à elle a créé
1 création d'une autre entreprise ayant
découvert des personnes qui vivent leur
réalité au quotidien et au travers d une
entreprise qui fait qu'ils proposent des
économies d'eau aux professionnels et
donc du coup cette entreprise c'est
c'est un nouveau tremplin pour moi c'est
extraordinaire de vivre de voler de ses
propres ailes et je passe d'un métier de
technicien un métier d'agent commercial
de nouvelles opportunités s'offrent à
moi c'est extraordinaire malgré tout
trois ans plus tard il faut que je
remette du beurre dans les épinards et
donc je choisi de reprendre à midi un
métier d'intérimaires pour faire un
schéma directeur d'assainissement de la
ville de libourne une super mission est
ce
le directeur avec qui j'étais en contact
me dit désolé maxime je peux pas t'en
embauché j'ai pas eu des marchés que je
voulais j'aurais bien aimé et ça tombe
bien parce que j'avais prévu
d'autres choses est de construire une
réalité tout aussi différente car en
2010 j'ai participé à la création d'une
association qui s'appelle dynamo et et 7
cette association apporte l'eau là où
elle n'est pas encore aujourd'hui à
travers le monde
il y à 7 6 personnes sur 10 qui n'ont
pas accès à l'eau potable et donc du
coup dynamo apportent de l'eau dans des
écoles rurales au maroc et au togo
c'est aujourd'hui 8 puis de construit et
presqu'autant de battre deux bâtiments
pour les toilettes et aujourd'hui les
pruneaux première nos premières missions
qu'on apportait au maroc c'est des
jeunes femmes qui ont accès à
l'université c'est des premières jeunes
femmes de ce village où on est intervenu
qui ont accès à l'université car elles
n'ont pas eu à faire la corvée d'eau et
en plus au moment de la puberté
elles n'ont pu avoir un espace
d'intimité et donc du coup de pouvoir ne
pas avoir un décrochage scolaire
important tous les mois fait
qu'aujourd'hui à son sont à l'université
ça c'est vraiment une fierté
extraordinaire pour dinamo et donc du
coup dans l'adn de nos projets on
travaille toujours en partenariat avec
une association locale et dynamos vient
en appui de cette association
et tout ça grâce à vous tous dans la
salle et car 1 % de vos factures peut
être dédié à l'eau et de l'accédant et
son accès à travers le monde
c'est une loi qui s'appelle oudin
santini qui a été créée il ya un peu
plus de dix ans et en 2016 ses 28
millions d'euros qui ont été alloués au
niveau national
à l'eau avec son accès à travers le
monde et donc du coup c'est génial c'est
extraordinaire mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut faire plus parce
que c'est à peu près 1 à 2 euros par an
par foyer et donc du coup la série 1 à 2
euros par an et ça permet de faire tant
de choses à travers le monde
c'est quand même extraordinaire et donc
c'est ce sont les élus de vos communes
qui ont le pouvoir de faire bouger et de
pouvoir allouer ce 1% pour l'au-delà
doivent dans santini et donc du coup que
c'est des élus qui s'engagent sur la
coopération internationale et du coup je
trouve ça comme extraordinaire 1 en 2015
les membres de dynamos prennent une
douche glacée à bordeaux aujourd'hui il
ya des personnes qui n'ont pas accès à
l'eau et donc du coup c'est des
personnes qu'on rencontre qui était
autour d'un pont qui traverse la garonne
et ces personnes vivent et sans eau sans
toilettes en plein été on trouve des
solutions rapides qui étaient totalement
illégales et donc du coup on essaye de
trouver des solutions car à ce moment là
je contacte mes anciens collègues qui
m'ont appris à 1 le fonctionnement du
réseau d'eau potable sur bordeaux et me
disent non mais ça on le connaît on
connaissait situation ces situations là
sont irrésoluble incroyable de
de voir des choses pareilles sur sur
bordeaux et donc ont participé à la
création d'un collectif composé
d'associations aux compétences diverses
et là dessus on essaie de trouver des
solutions pour apporter de l'eau là où
l'on peut voir des situations
incroyables avec des femmes enceintes
des nouveaux nés qui vise sur ces lieux
d'habitation et et ça c'est inadmissible
de voir ça encore aujourd'hui des
personnes qui n'ont pas accès à l'eau et
aux toilettes et donc on essaye de
également de réparer des fuites d'eau
aujourd'hui sur certains sites il ya 24
mètres cubes d'eau par jour donc 24
mille litres et pour vous imaginez ces
cinq jours de fuite c'est l'équivalent
de la consommation pendant un an d'une
famille de quatre personnes
c'est énorme et donc d'autant plus qu'
aujourd'hui l'eau que l'on consomme à
bordeaux pour la plus vieille elle est
tombée du temps de l'homme de cro magnon
c'est une eau qui n'a pas vu l'incident
ceux de nos pesticides de nos
médicaments donc il est notre
responsabilité aujourd'hui de la
préserver parce que elle est vraiment
vraiment cher cette eau là elle a
vraiment une valeur et donc pour revenir
la problématique de l'accès à l'eau et
donc aux différentes responsabilités
qu'on a pu rencontrer sur sur ce sujet
on peut dire aujourd'hui que la
compétence elle est complètement diluée
parce que théoriquement c'est un maire
qui est responsable de l'accès à l'eau
sur sa commune sur la plupart du temps
ces délégués un service des eaux
donc un syndicat des eaux donc tueur
bordeaux métropole s'est laissé bordeaux
métropole et
aujourd'hui c'est monsieur juppé en tant
que président de bordeaux métropole qui
a s'est transformée responsabilité de
l'accès à l'eau et et donc du coup on a
un dialogue donc avec différents
services des communes différents
services de bordeaux métropole
différents services de la préfecture du
département de la région de l'agencé
régionale de la santé de l' agence de
l'eau pour essayer de trouver des
solutions pour pour apporter de l'eau à
ces gens et tout ça aujourd'hui c'est
encore problématique trois ans de
travail plus tard car dans la
constitution française et inscrire le
droit à la propriété et pas le droit à
l'eau et donc on essaye de rencontrer
des rencontres aujourd'hui des
associations parisiennes pour essayer de
faire bouger des lignes au niveau de la
constitution
c'est pas simple mais il faut essayer
c'est important je trouve donc on essaye
de dénouer ce noeud et dans la plupart
des squats
quand on trouve des fuites il faudrait
réussir à résoudre ces solutions et donc
du coup quand on est quand on ne parle
pas français et quand on va dans un
grand magasin qui vend des tuyaux fin
des rats cordeau il y en a tellement qui
l'ont perdue c'est hyper compliqué
aujourd'hui le plomberie et donc la
réalité des personnes vivant en squat
sait où en bidonvilles
ce sont des
des enfants la plupart du temps qui
émettent à 25 litres un bilan de 25
litres dans une poussette et qui vont
chercher de l'eau de 10 à 150 à 200
mètres au niveau d'un poteau incendie la
plupart du temps et donc cette réalité
c'est que ces personnes là n'ont pas
n'ont pas accès à ce fluide aussi
indispensable et si vous réfléchissez
tous les matins vous marchez vers l'eau
deux alliés aux toilettes vous prendre
une douche ou où allez vous faire un
café vous marchez vers l'eau et donc les
les personnes vivant en squat en plus de
marcher pour aller à l'eau la plupart du
temps sont pas au courant que que l'eau
potable l'eau est potable dans les
poteaux incendie donc en plus de ça ils
achètent à une bouteille d'eau vous
savez ce petit morceau tuyaux
saucissonné jetables qui est 300 fois
plus cher que l'eau du robinet est donc
en plus de ça quand on vient en squat on
est domicilié au centre communal
d'action sociale pour toute la partie
administrative et donc on a vu sur
certains squats des personnes qui
arrivent et à ouvrir un compteur d'eau
et donc un payer leurs factures et grâce
à cette facture d'eau il avait une
domiciliation et cette domiciliation
contrairement quand on inscrit dans les
centre communal d'action sociale et on
peut on peut ouvrir une entreprise et
donc ces personnes-là arrivé à revendre
leur domiciliation à d'autres choses qui
est assez incroyable
et quand on parle de factures d'eau on
se dit mais c'est personnel
elle devrait payer leurs factures
d'euros mais ces personnes là ne
reçoivent pas ses factures d'eau la
plupart du temps passé sur les squats ya
pas de boîte aux lettres et donc du coup
c'est le premier courriers que le
facteur rapporte est le facteur b
trouvant pas de boîte aux lettres
renvoie un à l'expéditeur
d'autant plus que les factures d'eau
c'est tous les six mois et la durée de
vie d'un squat et entre trois et six
mois
donc du coup ça pose des problématiques
assez impressionnante ne serait ce que
pour recevoir la facture non plus de la
payer
et donc on dans les dans les pays
africains où on intervient quand on
construit un puis on leur demande de
créer un comité de l'eau comité de
gestion des eaux et ce comité de gestion
de l'eau des eaux pour être calqué dans
dans les squats pour gérer tous les
fuites qui sont l'électricité
l'évacuation des ordures ménagères et
l'eau et pourquoi pas même d'internet
qui est quelque chose qui devient de
plus indispensable aujourd'hui sur au
niveau de la gironde la préfecture dit
qu'il y a
en mars 2018 qui a une centaine de
squats dont 80% sur la métropole en août
2010 8 en fait le tour de tous les
squats connu par nos partenaires car
dynamo se place toujours en acteurs
techniques et peint en acteur d'action
sociale est pas remis parmi ces 30 squat
que l'on visite et il ya 1200 24
personnes qui y vivent dont 600
personnes qui n'ont pas accès à l'eau ou
et aux toilettes les les fuites après
compteur qui existe dans les squats
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le moyen de
pouvoir les mesurer il faut une étude
poussée et une étude 2 ça se paye et on
essaye de trouver des soupes des fonds
pour pouvoir un pour pouvoir faire cette
étude là est donc aujourd'hui notre
réalité c'est que nous en tant que
citoyen on devrait être responsable tous
de cette problématique là et pour ça on
peut trouver des solutions et faire de
l'éducation populaire afin d'expliquer
aux personnes comment ne pas avoir de
factures d'eau trop salée
si je pose la question savez-vous le
mois dernier combien de dos vous avez
consommé en moyenne tous vous tous qui
êtes là je vous invite vraiment à le
relever votre compteur d'eau et de leur
faire un temps donné et de faire un
petit produit en croix est de savoir
combien d'eau vous avez consommé par
jour dans votre foyer c'est vraiment
indispensable aujourd'hui pour préserver
de la nappe d'eau car on peut économiser
que ce que l'on mesure
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]